hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es wieder
die antwort auf die frage die wir uns
alle tagtäglich stellen was koche ich
heute heute kochen wir ein richtig
leckeres rezept nämlich paprika sah die
hähnchen aus dem ofen mit mozzarella
überbacken und das ganze geht auch sehr
schnell wenig vorbereitung dafür macht
der open interest und ich zeige euch
hier erstmal die zutaten
wir benötigen hähnchenbrustfilet hier
habe ich salz und pfeffer für das
häkchen außerdem tiefkühl erbsen rote
paprika paprikapulver edelsüß etwas
curry salz und knoblauch hier habe ich
paprika markt könnte auch gerne
tomatenmark nehmen außerdem mozzarella
sahne und milch als allererstes kümmern
wir uns um das fleisch ich habe jetzt
hier eine ganze hähnchenbrust genommen
aber ich gebe jetzt nicht so in eine
auflaufform ist wenn wir jetzt noch ein
bisschen zu dick ich werde einmal
halbieren und dann nochmal
durchschneiden dann könnte es einfach
besser portionieren später
[Musik]
so das fleisch habe ich jetzt nicht nur
halbiert sondern auch durchgeschnitten
sagte den vorteil erstens ist es
schneller durch den ofen und zwei uns
könnt ihr das viel besser portionieren
und jetzt habe ich ihr salz und pfeffer
und gibt er jetzt noch mal über einen
wissen seit sind wir vor auf so das habe
ich jetzt von beiden seiten erledigt das
fleisch gebe ich jetzt ganz kurz an die
seite wir kümmern uns sozusagen die rote
paprika und ich mag rote paprika am
allerliebsten wenn ihr jetzt gelbe oder
grüne dort könnt ihr das natürlich auch
gerne nehmen jetzt werde ich erstmal den
strunk entfernen und dann werde ich das
sind kleine kreise oder wie sagt man auf
jeden fall werde ich sage euch es den
namen vergessen sei so sagt man noch
mehr in scheiben in scheiben schneiden
genau so ist zeigen so ist doch schon
verarztet worden und werde die
krankenschwester so was sie keine
schwester paprika erledigt und jetzt
nehmen wir uns mozzarella die zwei
kugeln vor
und die werde ich jetzt auch noch in
scheiben schneiden wer keine mozzarella
mag der kann natürlich auch ganz
normalen käse nehmen zum beispiel gouda
oder eben
so mozzarella ist auch erledigt und
jetzt sagen wir nur noch milch sahne und
die gewürze sowie das paprika markt und
diese zutaten die gebe ich jetzt ganz
einfach in eine schüssel und verrührt
die gut miteinander und wer kein paprika
mag der kann natürlich auch tomatenmark
nehmen aber vertraut mir mit paprika mag
schmeckt es noch mal ein bisschen besser
[Musik]
und die soße ist somit auch fertig hat
keine 30 sekunden gedauert und
mittelschichten wir alles in unserer
auflaufform ich fange jetzt an mit dem
fleisch und gibt es jetzt erst mal auf
dem boden und darüber gebe ich dann noch
paprika
[Musik]
also ich für meinen geschmack habt ihr
jetzt noch erbsen drauf gegeben also
nicht nur wirklich für den geschmack
sondern auch für die optik damit auch
was grün ist dabei ist ich bin unseres
rot ist und was grün ist und was gäbe es
könnte es und meist können wir auch ganz
gut passen stimmt müsste ich eigentlich
machen weil ich moment ich hole sie
ihren berater so und meint damit wird
auch noch etwas gelbes haben wir die
ampeln rot grün
das gebe ich jetzt auch noch locker
drauf wir können natürlich auch
beziehungen dazu geben meine schwester
magda keine zivilen ziele ich jetzt auch
dazu nehmen aber sie ist ja mit deswegen
bin ich mal so lieb und jetzt gebe ich
einfach nur noch die soße obendrauf
mozzarella drauf und dann schiebe ich
schon in den backofen
[Musik]
so und jetzt wann hat der auflauf in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
und unterhitze für 35 bis 40 minuten und
ich da wir das ganze jetzt noch zu reis
und den mache ich es in der zwischenzeit
und dann könnt ihr euer leckeres paprika
sahnehäubchen servieren wie gesagt ich
sage jetzt mal ganz gerne mit reis dazu
passen jetzt aber auch nudeln zum
beispiel oder ist einfach so ist auch
sehr lecker
die portionen die mengenangaben die
reichen für vier personen und dann
wünsche ich euch jetzt ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen
ich freue mich natürlich wie immer über
eure fotos mit dem hashtag in sketchen
auf instagram und facebook folgt mit
dort wenn es nicht schon längst tut und
hier natürlich sowieso also ein
kostenloses aber soll ich mir auf jeden
fall da lassen wir nicht verpassen
möchte und dann sage ich bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]